[Musica]
[Applauso]
Buongiorno a tutti inizio la mia
presentazione parlando di due miei amici
Christian e Roberta loro hanno indagato
sulle proprie origini le proprie origini
in una maniera molto particolare hanno
inviato un po' della loro saliva ad una
società che scopre le origini delle
persone a partire dall'analisi del DNA
in che maniera in una maniera molto
semplice Noi siamo Infatti il prodotto
genetico del DNA dei nostri genitori che
a loro volta lo sono dei nostri nonni
che a loro volta lo sono dei loro
genitori quindi in noi Ci sono le tracce
del DNA dei nostri antenati che
potrebbero provenire da luoghi diversi
vediamo Infatti i risultati di Cristian
e Roberta dopo questo test genetico
Christian come vediamo ha una grande
percentuale di DNA simile a quello di
persone che attualmente vivono in Italia
ma allo stesso momento vediamo che una
buona parte del suo DNA e appartenente o
è simile a quello di persone che vivono
nell'est Europa in particolare in
Slovenia se invece vediamo i risultati
di Roberta osserviamo come il suo dna
sia sempre simile a quello di persone
che vivono e abitano in Italia al
momento e allo stesso tempo ha dei
segnali di
DNA simile a quelli di persone che
abitano la Grecia o la penisola arabica
e l'iran qua vediamo che sono due
profili diversi ma in realtà Dobbiamo
considerare come vedremo fra poco che le
differenze sono veramente minime Quindi
da questo vediamo che
che noi siamo un mosaico di geni
ereditato dai nostri antenati che c'era
una storia millenaria ed è proprio qua
che con questo Talk vi voglio portare un
viaggio verso il passato a partire dai
dati del presente ma per far questo
dobbiamo
fare un passo indietro ho parlato molte
volte di DNA spesso si parla di DNA Ma
che cos'è il DNA Il DNA è una molecola
detta anche molecola della vita questa
molecola può essere estratta come nel
caso di Cristian e Roberta dalla saliva
ma allo stesso momento può essere
estratta anche dal sangue essa è
costituita da delle lettere queste
lettere sono sempre quattro a c g e t e
queste lettere il loro ordine il diverso
ordine rende me quello che sono e
Cristian o Roberta quello che sono o
chiunque persona quello che è queste
lettere sono tantissime sono circa 3,3
miliardi quindi e insieme caratterizzano
quello che noi chiamiamo il genoma
questo genoma si può quindi io posso
comparare il mio con quello di una
qualsiasi altra persona sulla Terra e
il loro ordine e le loro somiglianze
sono grandissimi Infatti il mio genoma è
simile per il 99,9% con quello di
qualsiasi altra persona che abita la
terra e quindi solo lo
0,1%, una lettera ogni mille è diversa e
proprio su questa differenza Si può
anche scoprire le proprie origini come
abbiamo visto precedentemente ora vi ho
parlato solo di due persone quindi di
due miei amici ma immaginiamoci uno
scoprire le origini su una popolazione
quindi
per esempio immaginiamo di scoprire le
nostre origini sulla popolazione
italiana ed è questo
quello che io ho cercato di fare insieme
a 30 altri ricercatori appartenenti a
università italiane ed estere ho cercato
Insomma di
dipingere creare un ritratto genetico
dell'Italia per far questo avevamo
bisogno di un campione quindi un una
serie di individui rappresentativa di
tutte l'Italia e dove sono stati presi
questi campioni questi campioni sono
stati presi in un'occasione molto
particolare l'adunata degli alpini del
2013 in questa occasione è stato Infatti
possibile raccogliere i campioni di
moltissime persone perché perché durante
questo
durante questo evento migliaia di
persone appartenenti a luoghi diversi
dell'Italia si trovavano nello stesso
momento nello stesso luogo
e questi campioni da questi campioni è
stato estratto il DNA e il DNA è stato
comparato con quello anche di altre
popolazioni europee e mondiali e questo
è il risultato
il risultato è una mappa genetica
dell'Europa in questa particolare figura
in questo particolare grafico noi
vediamo che Ciascun individuo è
rappresentato da un puntino e la sua
posizione nel grafico è
il riassunto del suo genoma quindi vuol
dire che puntini più vicini hanno un
genoma simile puntini più lontani hanno
un genoma molto diverso ha una prima
vista questa cartina questa mappa
genetica dell'Italia e dell'Europa non
ci dice nulla ma nel momento in cui noi
ci posizioniamo vicino una cartina
geografica la cosa diventa molto
interessante Infatti vediamo che come la
disposizione dei paesi su una cartina
genetica ricorda quella geografica con
anche i mari evidenziati Infatti se
osserviamo a sinistra dei Balcani c'è
uno spazio bianco e questo spazio
cioccolato bianco rappresenta il mare
Adriatico Ma gli italiani come Si
posizionano in questa
in questa cartina Si posizionano in
questa maniera tutti i puntini colorati
sono gli italiani colori simili indicano
una appartenenza genetica simile quindi
i puntini azzurrini Avranno qualcosa di
più simile dei puntini per esempio
marroni e la cosa diventa ancora più
interessante nel momento in cui questi
campioni questi individui vengono
rappresentati in base alla loro origine
e la loro origine
porta a questa rappresentazione
In poche parole Noi vediamo che
sorprendentemente campioni che hanno una
genetica
simile quindi campioni per esempio
azzurrini Si posizionano in una parte
sono originari di una parte dell'Italia
mentre campioni
marroni Si posizionano in un'altra parte
e proprio dalla mappa genetica la mappa
genetica ricorda in maniera sorprendente
la mappa geografica con anche il tacco
dello stivale dell'Italia evidenziato Vi
faccio notare come in questa cartina
genetica l'Italia occupi un grande
spazio quindi è molto allungata questo
per quale motivo il motivo è semplice in
Italia Noi abbiamo
riscontrato Si riscontra la maggiore
variabilità ed Europa genetica Insomma
l'Italia una variabilità genetica
paragonabile a quella dell'inte in
Europa e più alta di altri Stati europei
quindi se noi prendiamo per esempio
Cristian e Roberta Loro sono diversi
tanto quanto potrebbero è potrebbe
esserlo un uno spagnolo un Danese e
ricordo faccio un inciso questa
diversità è minima e solo lo zero e solo
calcolata all'interno dello 0,1% di
diversità e questo per quale motivo Noi
siamo così variabili o diversi perché
siamo stati in Italia è sempre stata un
Crocevia di Popoli e
di Popoli che si sono susseguiti
l'uno con l'altro durante la nostra
storia Qua la domanda sorge spontanea
Quali sono stati questi popoli e per
rispondere a questa domanda viene il
nostro aiuto un nuovo
viene il nostro aiuto un un nuovo attore
che è il DNA antico Infatti dai primi
anni 2000 è stato possibile estrarre il
DNA a partire da reperti archeologici
anche datati decina di migliaia di anni
fa questo DNA letto non più cioè letto
alla stessa maniera di come è stato
letto Quello moderno è possibile
confrontarlo e quindi da questo
confronto i
da questo confronto è possibile ricavare
o valutare quali sono state le
migrazioni che hanno caratterizzato le
varie popolazioni in questo caso
l'Italia Adesso vediamo cosa è presente
nel genoma degli italiani e appartiene
alle popolazioni antiche come prima cosa
Vediamo che
l'Italia nel genoma degli italiani
abbiamo identificato un segnale un
segnale appartenente a quelle
popolazioni che per prime sono uscite
dall'Africa e hanno colonizzato l'Europa
e che si sostentavano principalmente di
raccolta e Pesca
queste popolazioni sono giunte in Europa
in epoca paleolitica circa 50.000 anni
fa successivamente abbiamo identificato
un nuovo segnale questo nuovo segnale un
questo segnale deriva da delle
popolazioni invece di epoca neolitica
sono quelle popolazioni che gli
archeologi
per le quali gli archeologi si
riferiscono che hanno introdotto la
l'agricoltura in in Europa e anche in
Italia successivamente abbiamo scoperto
altri due segnali risalenti all'epoca
del bronzo il primo
appartenenti a delle popolazioni nomadi
delle steppe russe che hanno introdotto
il loro DNA in noi ma allo stesso modo
anche il cavallo o la ruota parallela
abbiamo scoperto dal DNA un'altra
migrazione che
dall'anatolia nello stesso periodo è
giunta in Italia passando molto
probabilmente dalla Grecia Infine
abbiamo definito all'interno del genoma
italiano quello che noi chiamiamo un
segnale Pam Mediterraneo il quale è
stato introdotto soprattutto nel genoma
dei dei studi italiani durante il
medioevo e durante la dominazione araba
quindi se noi
prendiamo
in esame quello da dove da cui siamo
partiti quindi genoma di Cristian e
genoma di Roberto vediamo che questi
segnali sono ancora presenti in noi sono
presenti anche in queste due persone
questo per concludere vi fa capire come
l'Italia sia stata sempre e da sempre da
millenni un Crocevia di Popoli e culture
si sono susseguiti e che ci hanno
arricchito e probabilmente lo sarà anche
negli anni a venire io concludo questa
presentazione
Ringraziando e facendo un grazie
speciale alle persone che hanno
contribuito a questa ricerca una di
queste è Cristian Quindi nonostante il
mio amico e anche uno dei ricercatori
che ha ideato e contribuito questo
studio Serena e Francesco e anche un
grazie infinito tutte le persone che
hanno mi hanno aiutato nella
realizzazione nel workflow di questa
presentazione Grazie mille a tutti
[Applauso]